(audience cheering)
- Ah!
- Have y'all met before?
- No. Never.
- No. Nice to meet you.
- And congrats!
- Nice to meet you.
Thank you very much.
- This doesn't even mean
anything, but you have great hair.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah.
I just like, you walked out
here, and I was like, "Okay."
Yeah, yeah.
(Gabriel laughs)
I don't even know if you're talented,
I'm just saying I'm gonna
start with your hair.
(Gabriel laughs)
So, in the movie,
Steven Spielberg directs
you playing a version
of Steven Spielberg.
Wow! That had to be intimidating.
(Amy chuckles)
Did you get to spend any time with him?
'Cause I know, didn't y'all shoot this,
some during COVID times?
Like when you had to,
kind of, be separate?
- We spent a lot of
time Zooming beforehand,
'cause everything that
happens to my character,
happened to him.
- Yeah.
- And so,
I wanted to understand what
story he wanted to tell.
So that just meant getting to know him.
- Yeah!
- And I could
just ask him questions about
his life, and get to know him.
- [Kelly] That's kinda cool.
- That was really cool.
- Just getting to sit
with Steven Spielberg,
- And be like, "So?"
- Oh, yeah!
- Yeah.
(Gabriel laughs)
That's kinda really cool,
- Just getting to know him-
- No, it was amazing.
- As a human, 'cause he's so magnificent.
- Oh, and he's a great guy.
- Yeah.
- That's what I love-
- Oh, that's cool!
- Finding out about him,
that he is not just this-
"Yeah, I did E.T."
(Amy and Kelly laugh)
He's great.
- No big deal.
- Yeah.
- He's a really good person.
I love it.
So, did you feel any pressure?
'Cause it's like one thing,
you wanna impress people
that have this script
and whatever character you're
playing to be impressive,
in that sense.
But to play someone who's directing you,
- Mm hmm!
- And is such a huge icon,-
- You know, in this industry.
- Yeah!
- [Kelly] Did you feel
pressure 'cause of that?
- Oh, yeah!
You don't want to be the guy
who ruins his life story.
(Amy and Kelly laughing)
Like, you don't, you know.
- I love how you said it.
- Yeah. That would be horrible.
And just the ensemble
of people around you.
- Michelle and Paul,
- Yeah!
- And Steven and Tony and Kristie,
And even just, everyone.
Like, you're surrounded
by masters the whole time.
Even the A camera operator, Mitch;
he's stormed the beaches of Normandy
with a handheld camera
for Saving Private Ryan.
- Yeah!
- Everywhere around you
are just the best of the best.
- And,
- Opportunity!
What a cool one, yeah.
- You wanna keep up.
- So is it true though,
that you were once in a stage version,
I love this,
(Amy chuckles)
of "Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure?"
- Yeah, that was the play we did
in my senior year of high school.
- I love that-
- Way to go!
- What a cool school!
- This is a play.
- Oh, yeah.
- I know!
Our's were like...
I mean, they were fine,
but they were the classic ones
that everybody always does.
I just thought that was
very progressive and cool.
- Oh, well it was...
I didn't take the drama class,
but the kids who did,
their assignment was to write
this play, and adapt a play,
and they chose "Bill and
Ted's Excellent Adventure."
- Oh!
- And so one of my friends
from football and rugby, MC, he was like,
"Yeah, I'm writing it.
Come, audition to be Bill."
and like, "Let's audition
together as Bill and Ted",
and we did and we both got it.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, that sounds so fun.
- It was a lot of fun.
- I know, this is not a joke,
I literally learned
certain historical figures
(Amy laughs)
- From that movie.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- We'll take education-
- Wherever we can get it.
- I was like,
look, before Hamilton came around,
I was learning from Bill and Ted.
- Yep! Socrates.
- Oh, yeah.
- It's entertaining,
and something historical
you're learning about.
So, what's the strangest
play you've ever done?
- Wow! God, that's a good question.
I feel like I was a snowflake.
(Kelly laughs)
You know?
- Oh, wow!
- In second or third grade.
And she didn't really have an arc.
We don't know
what her character was.
(Kelly laughs)
It was a mess.
- Well, hey, there are no small parts.
They're the only small actors.
- That's right.
- Gabriel understands.
- Oh, okay. I like that.
- That's true.
- Is that a thing people say?
- I've never heard that.
- Yes.
- Oh!
(Gabriel laughs)
- I'm not an actor.
- They usually say it
to the people that have small parts.
(all three laughing)